[Applause]
these people are going nuts for you
it's crazy
yeah fans went crazy for tom but boy was
he mesmerized when his leading lady
arrived his spidey senses kicked in just
as our interview was getting started so
how are you feeling about that and
tackling that they're losing things i
think it just sounds like that just
showed up tom leaned over to look and
for 15 sweet seconds the 25 year old
stood in his tracks putting everything
on hold to watch his girlfriend make her
way to the red carpet oh she's going in
she's going in she's gone
minutes later they posed together
zendaya wore a custom valentino
spiderweb dress and tom a prada suit i
honestly feel a little bit numb like
this has been the most incredible
experience this whole journey from the
day i got cast this means the world to
me can we just like stay up here all day
it is so crazy down there spider-man no
way home is in theaters friday and
breaking news tom better hold on to that
spidey suit we are starting on what the
next story could be
and we certainly want that to be with
tom holland if they'll help me back i'll
be there tom's co-star benedict
cumberbatch was also gushing about him
i'm really proud of him i know it sounds
patronizing but you know he's younger
than me like i said before to get to see
him from the moment i remember bounding
across the concrete at long crosses
awful studio we have to shoot a lot of
marvel stuff in england hello i'm tom
i've just been cast a new spider-man i
was like wow
wow congratulations jamie foxx who's
back as electro had another reason to
celebrate it's amazing and it's my
birthday it is your birthday come on
and so we're here to celebrate
[Applause]
can i give you a little birthday gift
take you back to the very first
spider-man premiere
look at that
look at that
look at this
look at this right here
i think it's amazing